fighting
fighting would you do it i think about
that a lot
talk to me yeah i would love to do it
because but i trained yeah i've trained
a few i i mean which disciplines jiu
jitsu and
some hands or no muay thai okay yeah
generally with a guy as as like muscular
as you i would say there's no way you
can strike and then i saw you dunk
yeah and i was like this guy might be
[ __ ] this guy might be able to box a
little bit it's the thing that i that
the biggest my biggest i'm talking about
like sometimes you see the big guys try
to strike and they're like throwing
pillows yeah yeah they can push because
you guys are so used to push motion yeah
but snapping a punch is is a way
different
of course but you must have fast twitch
if you can [ __ ] dunk from the vert
yeah
so but for me it's like i know the thing
that i lack the most if i'm talking
about fighting like being like honestly
like genuinely honest about this yeah i
know that i would need to
train specifically like cardiovascular
yeah like i'd have to be like doing bjj
like every day i'd have to be doing
striking every day because like reduce
mass a little bit too yeah like i'd have
to lose weight for sure is that bjj
brazilian
yeah you're like is there a new
type of
but yeah because carrying 260 like those
muscles need oxygen yeah you're [ __ ]
there's like unless like
you know you've unless i as i gained
this weight i was also doing all that
stuff so your cardio would match exactly
but i wasn't right so like my cardio
would match like you know a [ __ ] a
bodybuilder would be like i'm spending
time doing this yeah yeah but if as i
was gaining that weight i was also
striking and i was also doing bj i was
also doing all the fighting training
like sports disciplines yeah yeah
disciplines exactly then i'd be like
okay as i went up and wait you know
because i must've been eating crazy
amounts of food to get to that and to
maintain that then i would be like okay
i'm more adapt for that but i know that
i haven't been so it's like i haven't
been doing enough of it i've been doing
more of the other so i know i'd have to
shift my training now you see these guys
you see obviously like jake and logan
making crazy money yeah right and you're
like oh wow there is a space for
celebrity
fighting yeah it's crazy and you happen
to have experience in the discipline
you're not learning it i mean like jake
and logan learned how to box over the
last three years yeah you've been
training jiu jitsu longer or less i'm
not not as consistent like i'd be more
like you the consistent and consistency
you're in it a little bit then you pull
that in a little yeah but i've even
watched some videos like you know some
stuff like you can choke some people out
for sure okay so there has to be part of
you that's going like
should i enter this
yeah definitely like would you want to
i'd love to i'd like to do i'd like to
do the ufc thing i'd like to i don't
want to do the boxing thing if i was
going to fight it wouldn't be boxing
because you have more experience than
jiu-jitsu well
yes but i'd also like just like to use
my whole body like if i was going to put
my face and my like my my reputation on
the line yeah yeah i don't want to be
like just relying on striking because i
know that i'd like to like i like to
ground and pound someone yeah yeah who
do you want what makes the biggest fight
because you're somebody who understands
the internet as well like what is what
is the headline that's like i mean it's
one of those guys it's jake it's jake
jake or logan logan jake is the number
one right now because he's the number
one guy in it if you fought jake in mma
do you think you handle that
yeah for you
yeah i beat the [ __ ] out of him right
now really
in mma in mma
no because the kid can fight no and i
think a lot of people underestimated him
i i fully agree yeah i fully agree i'm
just saying based on my weight
exactly you get on top of them and the
experience in jiu jitsu and it's just
like that's why i know if i'm striking
nah i'm gassing the [ __ ] out and there's
no way i'm gonna be able to hang like
that for long enough so you basically
you're gonna try to take them down as
quick as possible like take me through
that first round with you and jake yeah
because i know you've thought about it i
know you've thought about it take me
through the first round
i mean it'd be simple you're avoiding
the right hand i would out i would avoid
i would avoid it and i'd take him down
and i'd and i hate to say this but i
would i would just tire him out for the
first like few rounds meaning like body
weight holding him down pressure that
that [ __ ] restricting pressure
grappling cardio is a pressure pressure
pressure yeah and then get him tired and
then probably won the rounds do the same
thing and then just ground and pound
so not try to tap out
no probably not you don't think he'd
give up that back bro maybe maybe i
think you might give up but i want to
[ __ ] oh you want to finish yeah i
want to i want to be like i want blood
yeah i want blood miners i don't give a
[ __ ] i want blood actually got to be
blood interesting yeah are you worried
at all about like [ __ ] up your face
like you're good
if i got to that point no right if i'm
fighting him no way but because there's
so much money that you can fix it
exactly like if you're talking about now
okay if i gotta go through the ufc i
gotta fight a bunch of guys to get there
yeah yeah no bro yeah i'm gonna get like
[ __ ] up yeah yeah yeah but if it's
just it's all for that i'm not worried
about it interesting okay now what about
now logan can wrestle a bit
yeah would you be worried at all with a
person with a wrestling background i
tried to wrestle logan i tried to do
that would never happen
did logan i don't know
i mean he's listen at the same time
logan is i'm not the kind of guy to be
like oh i'm honest like logan's [ __ ]
you know if he doesn't want to wrestle
me it's because like maybe he thinks he
has more clout he does i'm not i'm not
he has something to lose in that
situation for sure
he's got he's got more clout i mean i'm
gonna [ __ ] be a liar like yeah i got
more [ __ ] this is obviously yeah yeah
this guy's one of the most famous people
so like for him to take that and to lose
that there's more to lose right but it
would still be like a fun wrestling
match for you guys for sure and also you
would argue that he's at a disadvantage
for weight yeah you're a big guy you've
experienced wrestling too or just
jiu-jitsu i mean not not specific
wrestling no that's the thing about
jiu-jitsu is like jiu jitsu starts when
wrestling finishes
yeah it's [ __ ] right like he gets you
where he thinks he wants you and you're
like welcome on the back yeah yeah right
exactly
so that's where it might be a little bit
unfair just a wrestling match might be
towards him but if it's a grappling
match where there is yeah if we're just
wrestling i mean i mean i'm sure his
technique is better because i know that
he's done more wrestling yeah and i know
that he has more cardiovascular
endurance than me that's for sure right
he's a lighter guy i know he's been
doing i don't know how much he's been
doing right
but then grappling cardio is different i
keep telling people you see this in ufc
all the time you see guys like this
happened to dustin
yeah yeah dustin pouria is cardio is
amazing any fight i've never seen dustin
get gas throwing to the end of the
rounds when he's throwing
yeah but when he has to fight off the
ground
it's just different man it's a difficult
party have you done it
never i i've been just like i've you
know rogan's tapped me out and that kind
of stuff like that just jokingly but
like never like grappling never done
anything
it is so [ __ ] hard yeah it's because
it's it's obviously like the the animal
instinct of like fight or flight so your
your adrenaline your heart rate's higher
so then like oxygen usage is going way
up and this because like brazilian jiu
jitsu is like if it's all about being
calm and if you're not
like you're skipping breathing heavy
you're going if you're not scared you
get into it you're like [ __ ] and then at
the same time the person is doing stuff
where you're like i don't know like
where are they going if you're un
unskilled with the actual techniques you
know that they're coming for something
and if you don't know how to defend it
you're getting scared because your
heart's just setting up yeah and then at
the same time pressure right the
pressure of like you know imagine every
time you breathe you take a breath out
and then that person like a good a good
one will get they're going to get a
little deeper so you can breathe a
little less each time they're trying to
constrict your legs so imagine like
they're like pressure so like you're
having your recovery is going so now
everything you do is like you're heavier
you can't you're not you're not really
throwing hard punches because they're
like throwing [ __ ] pillows